il ya des mosquées les autres se faire
vacciner ou non le choix se présentera à
toutes les familles du pays dans les
prochains mois
cette clinique de montréal nord a
justement été aménagé en prévision de ce
futur pas si lointain
actuellement on donne la vaccination
contre la grippe une en quelques mois ça
va être un super duo est utilisé pour la
vaccination contre la creuse wierde au
moins 400 personnes par jour pourront se
faire vacciner ici donc et si je vais
vous amener ou est ce qui pourrait
éventuellement avoir lé nouveau frigo
avec fin l'espace est déjà réservé le
canada recevra des millions de doses
mais les canadiens le prendront-ils
certains cas ça nous pose des questions
à savoir quand est ce qu il sera
disponible tout ce qu'est ce qu'on en
pense
je pense que yockey ça arrive on fait
nous avons posé la question
un sondage ipsos radio canada révèle que
64 % des canadiens se feront vacciner
contre la coved 19 21% sont incertains
et 16 % ne le ferons pas nous partis la
population vit ce jour peut-être qu'on
est un peu trop vite c'est pas
merveilleux mais c'est pas de désastre
une ope le fait que 20 % soit un certain
je pense que c'est normal
la docteure du bmn des sondages sur la
question depuis le printemps
elle observe que l'appui à la
vaccination a reculé
cette tendance à la baisse a été
observée dans d'autres études
canadiennes puis aussi à travers le
monde dans les 24 48 voire injection
donc j'irai peut-être j'attends
peut-être un mois ou deux cette
hésitation est évidente dans notre
sondage parmi ceux qui prendront le
vaccin 36 % le front le plus rapidement
possible mais 38% attendront un mois aux
2 15% attendront plusieurs mois et 11 %
ne savent pas quand il le feront
peut-être
j'attendrai une semaine je sais pas pas
sûr
je comprends que les gens veuillent
attendent mais d'attendre en fait si ça
fonctionne pas parce que si les gens se
prennent les pieds pendant encore six
sept mois le problème c'est qu'on va
être dans un confinement déconfinement
continuer mais si certains sont
réticents la raison semble clair parmi
tous les répondants jusqu'à 71 %
même ceux qui se feront vacciner disent
craindre de possibles effets secondaires
oui on veut se faire vacciner mais on y
va un petit peu à reculons en ce moment
ses loques que le travail de sa
république devenu important de bien
expliquer pour embobiner convaincre les
gens d'aller se faire vacciner sans trop
attendre toutes les étapes de production
d'un vaccin ont été respectées nous
disent les experts
mais certains se méfient de la rapidité
du processus
peut-être c'est bon voici les américains
ils vont en prendre ça va
dans cette clinique en tout cas tout est
prêt pour vacciner
jeunes et moins jeunes généralement les
gens nous y stocker de revenir nous voir
quand ça va être là tant pour la
vaccination contre la colère gronde le
plus rapide que le mieux pour revoir
notre famille nos amis puis de moitié
leur devoir travailler 5 6 kg et ma
santé plus que quelques mois la lumière
points au bout du tunnel
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morin